All right guys, so here is the last example for the ITT silver bullet.
So as you can see, I'm at 950 or 55ish and I can see this clear bi-site liquidity here and
you can see if we take out this liquidity here, we can look for for lower prices. We can
anticipate that price is going to go lower. Okay, so we have the liquidity sweep here. Let's go back
we'll go back to the one minute timeframe and look for a clear market structure shift
and we also do have another bi-site liquidity sweep here, right, and let's see how this plays out.
Okay, perfect. So you can see we have a higher high, higher low, higher high here,
and that is like the prime market structure shift where you have like this tiny structure
broken right here. So now what we do have is a very tiny favorably gap and also this volume
imbalance, kind of volume imbalance. Remember that topic? Yeah, so we do want to talk, we do not want
to take like volume imbalance into consideration. This is favorably gap. So now that would be our
entry point and let's go short right there, put our stop at the high here. That is 1.82 handles.
Totally opposite from what ICT says. And let's go for 1 to 2. And let's see how this plays out.
We have our entry at 1044. So remember, no entry after 1050. So let's see how this plays out.
And price goes ahead and hits our take profit. If price broke this structure right here before
coming back to the entry, then that would be a very, very low probability setup. Because we are
not looking for internal market structure, sorry, external market structure, but we're looking for
a break off internal market structure, something like that. Okay, fractal market structure shift.
We do not want to look for a huge market structure shift like this one. I hope that clears everything
about ICT silver bullet. Essentially, I'm going to repeat this rule again. Identify liquidity sweep,
right? Mark out liquidity that has not been swept yet. Market structure shift on one minute and entry.
Yeah, so this right here is our liquidity level that is yet to be swept. Okay, so we also have
this liquidity sweep right here. If we go to market structure shift somewhere around here,
we would have taken our entry and we could have targeted these levels here, which is like liquidity,
resting liquidity here. So let's say if we got our market structure shift here, that would be my
target essentially, but I would only go for one to two regardless of my liquidity level. I would
not target this if my one to two was hit. So essentially, you can see if I held the trade here,
you can see the price took out this liquidity level right here. And let's see how the price goes.
And yes, it reversed right after taking out this, this liquidity here. And also this, actually it did
not take out this level here. It just took out this structure here and then boom. So that was it,
guys, rewatch this video again and again, and practice this again and again, and you're going
to learn the strategy and you're going to master this strategy. I'll see you guys in the next one.